[Music]
Oh Mukai, are you back already?
I'm useless with this kind of troublesome power [Music] I've worked out
overseas By
concentrating on my fists and knees, I'm going
to strengthen it strongly This
is the top class among pure wounds If she ever loses
Takeuchi  Kun,
you can't get stuck anymore It's
troublesome if you get caught with your Nen ability
[Music]
Don't listen too much
Was the card thick yesterday
[Music] I was
surprised You came all this
way
Why
are you crying Why am I a woman  I have to beat people too What is
it? My
master said that the
guy who raises his hand to a woman is the most unpopular in the world
You're a gentleman, but that's an insult
I want to fight on an equal footing with you
come regardless